BE CAREFUL.
RIGHT IN FRONT TO TAKE PULLING
BACKHAND TO THE FOREHA
CALL IT AND HE DOES NOT EVEN
GET ALL OF THIS.
AND NOW THEY COME IN TRANANHIS
WAIT TO GET THE OFFICIAL RULES
BY THAT.
AS THEY WERE CAPPED OUT
IS THERE WORKING THEIR WAY IN
AS THE TAKE THE
TAKE OVER ONTO THE ANAHEIM
BENCH.
ALON
THE POWER-PLAY OPPORTUNITY THAT
IS OVER AND THEY THIN THREE FOR
WITH THE DRAW LEADING TO THE
GOAL AND HERE THEY
AND WHAT A TURN
COMING IN MOMENTARILY WITH
GREAT WORK ALONG NTESTED AS HE
THE SCREEN.
SCOTT WEDGEWOOD HAD A BEAT ON
SIX MINUTES TO PLAY AT THE
HONDA CENTER.
THIS IS WHEN THEY60 MINUTESVE.
AND THEY GET F OF THE STICK AND
COYOTES IN THE SIX-GAME SKID.